great thank you guys so much for joining
I first wanted to get a brief glimpse of
the room
who here has already done probablistic
programming sort of knows what that is
if you could just raise your hand okay
great and assume the rest of you are
probably here to like learn what what
that is about so it's always challenging
with the talk like that you sort of want
to please both audiences and keep it
interesting so what I'm going to do is
the first half of the talk is my best
attempt at trying to explain that to
someone with a technical background and
really introduce you to what that all
means and and how to think about it in
the right way with some very simple
examples and then basically I'm gonna
switch it up a little bit and do much
more advanced example so maybe if you
don't follow that last part that's fine
if you're boring during the first part
hopefully that second part will be
interesting to you and I really enjoy
giving that talk at conferences like PI
data mainly because for me probabilistic
programming is a great approach for
doing statistics if you come from an
engineering perspective because mostly
the model building and the inference is
all done in code so you don't and you're
not standing in front of white board all
the time
deriving math equations but it's a much
more engineering driven approach there's
a disclaimer the example that I'm going
to use to motivate all this it's
actually not going to be just like some
abstract problems but a very concrete
problem that I encountered as the the
data scientist at quanto Qian so I'm
basically kind of motivated using that
and if you're wondering what quanto pian
is we are a algorithmic trading platform
and we have over seventy thousand users
seventy thousand users worldwide and
they come to the website and they have
we have a community forum where people
talk about algorithmic trading ideas and
share code and everything we have in
browser backtester where you can write
Python
to build your strategies to invest in
the stock market and we provide you with
14 years of high-quality historical data
to test these strategies you can then
deploy them in the in the market with
real money trading we have trading
competitions where it can win money but
mainly our business model is then in
detecting the talent out of that pool
70,000 users we hope that well we know
that some of those I actually really
know what they're doing and have a
talent for this so for and then actually
we invest capital outside capital in
these strategies and we share the
profits with a quant the other two
important things is the platform is
completely free everyone can use it so
it's a great way to just have fun and
explore it and maybe get started in
quantitative finance if interest in that
but for me as a data scientist it really
becomes a problem of well how do how do
we find these strategies how do we
decide whether strategy is actually
viable or not and this is a type of plot
that we look at a lot and it's the
cumulative attorneys of that strategy on
the y-axis over time so this is a two
year back test where someone builds
strategy and it's buying selling stocks
and these are the cumulative returns and
you can see basically it's just like
this complete upwards line as most back
tests actually look like so in those two
years it's turning an 800 percent profit
which is absolutely amazing right so
it's the money printing machine what
what could possibly go wrong
often though with back tests there's a
tendency to overfit so they're often
look much better than in reality then
when you actually set them live and this
specific example is actually a an
algorithm that was submitted to one of
our trading competitions and the way
that is set up is you submit a to your
back test and then we let it run in this
case for one month on out-of-sample data
so that's that very small blue line very
limited the data and then if you do well
in both of those in both of those mats
then you you you do well in the contest
basically so there's both of these
things in and
the the big test whether something is
viable Mars is gonna be here in the in
the paper trading because he couldn't
have had access to that data and overfit
on that data because it just hadn't
happened yet another way to look at that
problem is instead of cumin returns he
I'm just looking at daily returns of the
both of those distributions and now it
becomes maybe much more clear what the
problem really is and how difficult it
is is your task is to decide well you
have a lot of data of that histogram
here in for the backtest in blue and
it's looking pretty good right so you
have one percent returns in a single day
that's pretty good and that happens
fairly regularly and then you have the
out-of-sample period of just twenty days
and now the question becomes do those
two sample sets come from the same
distribution and now as a data scientist
there's multiple approaches you might
take and so I thought it might be
interesting to try and compare these and
just put probablistic programming into
the global landscape of what is out
there in terms of like data science
tools you can use and I mean everyone
likes machine learning right so maybe we
could do that somehow so you have data
this black box classifier some are more
black box than others and that's bits or
predictions and actually I mean it
already is like a parent that is not the
right tool for the job and maybe like
you train a classifier to distinguish
between those two and if it can do that
then now from separate distributions but
doesn't really work right it's not
really the right the right framework for
solving this problem and a more general
point is also that these black box
machine learning algorithms are often
very bad at conveying what they have
learned right that's why they that's why
the black box is you can't really look
inside that it's like some super
nonlinear thing like I don't know random
forest of like hundreds of decision
trees and if you are a data scientist
and part of your job is to actually
provide insight into your data right how
are you going to do that with a black
box tool
moving on to frequency statistics I
there you again have data and we could
run a hypothesis test like a t-test to
say are those two different
distributions different and then there
we get a p-value and that basically
tells us of that is smaller than 0.05
then we say okay there's a significant
difference still this I think a few
number of things wrong with that
approach first of all I call this gray
box because you can look into what it's
doing but so there are many implicit
assumptions baked into that t-test that
are not like directly on the surface one
of them which is really critical is that
your data is normal distributed and with
algorithmic with stock returns in
general we know that that is just not
the case so these extreme market events
like in Oh 8 when the during the
financial crisis there were like market
swings over like 10 to 20 percent right
and these are really meaningful events
so you want to make sure that you
capture them but it means that your data
is not normally stupid buts heavy tails
and mostly people use normal
distribution sister the mathematical
convenience not because it's a
particularly good model of reality where
often you have outlier events and you
have to be robust so already this
assumption is often violated and you
might change them but that requires read
arriving all that math and finally the
p-value actually you often people assume
that is the probability that those two
samples come from different distribution
but there's actually completely wrong
it's it's a different probability but
people treat it isn't that so there's a
lot of misunderstanding where people
have a the wrong intuition about this
title about this type of test now lastly
to contrast that with probabilistic
programming we have what I call a white
box or box where you can build a custom
model for the specific problem that you
have and that model is very transparent
because you can just write that out in
computer code and then just look at it
and the best part is after you wrote
that model in code you can just automate
automate the inference process so before
with the frequent Cystic you have to do
math to do the inference here basically
you can run these general Markov chain
Monte Carlo algorithms that give you the
right answers and they they work on
almost any model that you throw that you
throw that and we are in a Bayesian
framework so we're dealing with actual
probabilities so in that case that
intuition what is the probability that
they come from the same distributions is
actually the right intuition behind that
and we can place priors to regularize
and all those good things so how can you
think about Bayesian modeling in general
and for me a very intuitive approach is
to think of it in terms of a generative
building generative models that tell you
how your data was generated so we have
observed data down here and then we
wonder how was that data generated
theoretically and often there's some
latent causes that we can't observe that
but that we want to infer from the data
so really you start from the top and say
okay these are the things that I think
are driving my data and underlying it
then you link that to the observed data
by making an assumption on the
distribution of that data and that can
be a normal distribution it can be a
student-t distribution if you want to
have more mass in the tails and be more
robust but you can switch all that out
so that's Bayesian modeling now
probabilistic programming is essentially
the implementation of that
oh sorry before that so this is how you
construct the model and this is how I do
inference backwards and this is just
applying Bayes formula which inverts
that model and gives you the most likely
latent causes for the data that you have
observed probabilistic programming now
automates a lot of that stack by just
allowing you to write this down in code
in computer code and prime c3 allows you
to do that in Python code and then you
just hit the inference button and you
get what is called the posterior the the
most likely values of your latent of
your parameters given the data
so now to come back to the problem that
we had initially we wanted to know do
those returns come from different
distributions so we want to model these
returns and this is what that would look
like so down here again we have our
observed data that's the daily returns
and here I'm not going to say that it's
a normal distribution which we know to
be wrong but actually student-t
distribution which is different in the
way that it has a third parameter that
allows you to create more mass in the
tails so more extreme events just are
more likely so it's a very nice
distribution to use in reality just
because it's much more robust and an
obvious efficient would be so instead of
two parameters for the normal
distribution the location or the mean
and the scale or standard deviation in
the case of the normal we have a third
parameter that controls the mass and the
tail so these are my parameters or the
latent causes that I wanna infer give
them the data and again inference then
works backwards and this is what the
model would look like in PI and C 3 and
it's not the best model that I'm billing
it's but it's I think the most trade of
model so every program will look fairly
similar so here I'm just importing
everything to be lazy and then there's
this with context and that's more of a
technicality I don't really have to
worry about that but essentially it
means that everything that happens
indented under here will be tied to this
model object and that Bailey is a way to
like keep all the things that you create
below that to a common thing but every
it's boilerplate code every model will
have that the more interesting part is
now I can define these latent causes my
parameters of the model right so these
are the three ones that I have and
because we're in a Bayesian setting we
have to place priors which are my
beliefs about these parameter values
without having seen any data and in this
case I'm just going to say and that is a
subjective choice that you can make as a
modeler and it gives you a lot of
freedom and power to actually inform
your analyses because often you do have
prior information going in for example
the case
no the mean returns of the strategy we
already know to be close to zero right I
mean it's not gonna be a hundred percent
daily average returns that's ridiculous
it's not going to be minus twenty
hopefully so in reality I might place a
normal distribution around that but here
I'm just going to say okay it's a
uniform distribution with equal
assigning equal probability to all
different parameter values in this range
from minus 100% 200% scale can only be
positive so I'm setting the lower bound
to zero and the tail can also the tail
parameter can also only be positive so
I'm saying that it was one to ten but as
I said you can and you should use
different prize than these just to be
more informative so uniform is like
often used distribution if you if you
sort of want to be uninformative but
actually it's it often pays off to be
informative and inform the model of what
you think is going on now the second
part is how do we tie that to data and
as I said we're using a t-distribution
oh and by the way the first argument is
just the name you can name the random
variables and here we pass in the data
so just that will just be an umpire
array and here we're using the observed
keyword which tells it actually that
this is used to infer these other
parameters yes you can also use improper
price and this is where you tie together
Bayley these parameters with the data
via the distribution function so when I
execute that in Python actually not all
that much happens so under the hood just
a technical note we using Theano
if you know what that is to build up a
compute graph out of all these
probabilities abused and on that we can
compile that to see behind the scenes
and that means it's fast it's just in
time compiled we can compute gradients
so Theon is really powerful as a
framework behind all of this but you're
not really exposed to that when using
prime c3 so that's why it just mention
that in passing but critically no
inference is going on
so we just built the model and now the
question is well how do we solve all
that math right so there's like this
whole thing going on that you have to
compute but as I said you can do that
automatically and model specification
and then turn to inference and that is
really simple because we just have to
instantiate a Markov chain Monte Carlo
sampler and what it has really given
this field a huge boost is this new
class of samples called Hamiltonian
Montecarlo and nuts is one of those and
those really work much better on
extremely complex models and PIME c3
that's main reason actually why we wrote
prime c3 is to be able to use this new
class of samplers and then you just draw
5,000 samples and and that will just
basically turn the bayesian crank and
and solve what we've given it and next
we can look at the answers that we care
about right so and we can plot these so
called posterior distributions and what
is really important now is that these
are not the returns that I'm plotting
here right these that's my belief in the
mean returns so that's just one
parameter of my model and you can just
compute the mean over the input array
that are passed in right and you get
back a single number but that number
does not tell you anything about the
confidence in that number right so with
more data it would be more accurate but
you have no way of knowing how accurate
that is right so here we're not dealing
with single numbers never we're dealing
with distributions over possible values
of parameters and that is encoded in
that rid of that distribution so
intuitively you can think okay in my in
sample set we have lots of data I have a
lot of confidence
so the pasal mean returns parameters
values that I can get or that I would
deem likely given my model is very
narrow so I have a lot of confidence I
know okay this is the value it's very
close to this one now with the off
sample set we have very little data so
we can't really say anything and that
naturally comes out of the model by just
giving me a wider posterior distribution
and if I had no data at all basically
then it would just be the prior where
just say well it's going to be uniform
everywhere
and all the time basically it will like
go tighter and tighter around the region
that is the true parameter yeah so the
price are uniform distribution
so they I'm just saying everything
without having seen the data everything
is going to be equally likely but then
there's a different thing which is the
likelihood function which is just how do
I think my data are distributed and that
I say as a student distribute a student
T distribution so it's the shape of the
data and my knowledge about the
parameters but now what is cool about
this is that once we have it in this
framework we can very easily ask
statistically meaningful questions about
that and if you remember the main
question was well do those two agree do
they come from the same distribution and
I can now ask what is the probability
that the mean returns of my in sample
strategy are below my mean returns in
the out-of-sample and I get back a
number that is like a hot probability
number so that is the probability that
we care about right and so three point
three four percent so a Bayesian test
that I just created out of nothing
basically tells me that these two are
likely to come from a different
distribution with a different mean so I
might not want to invest in that
strategy I'm gonna skip this but you can
also basically make predictions with
that but I'm going to show that in more
detail later but before moving on to the
next part I wanted to Billy tell you
what actually happened because we we got
to learn that before we had these tools
we had different ways of like comparing
the two periods and because that's javi
had such an amazing back test and the
forward the paper trading was still sort
of okay it actually won the contest and
we deployed a hundred thousand US
dollars to it and let it sit and market
for six months okay so who have things
knows what happened
is what happens so with these tools
basically we could have already earlier
been alerted to the fact that actually
this something did not seem to match up
with how good the back test was
promising the strategy to be and yes I
mean the most likely thing what had
happened is that the plant developing
the strategy just over fit on past it
and that happens all the time so it's
really important to discover that okay
so that is the introductory part so yeah
maybe two quick questions
understanding purposes well I mean you
mean just a different way of comparing
the posterior yeah that you can do that
too and I think actually that would give
you a similar answer but it's sort of a
distance metric so it's not it's not a
probability that you get yep so yeah you
can do that for me thinking in terms of
probabilities is more intuitive so
that's why is that
I understand
yep so the question is with only 25 days
of data what can you really say
shouldn't you have to wait more and the
answer is it depends right I mean if the
returns that you're getting are like
super poor and like you like tanks
immediately then like you don't need to
wait six months to know that right and
that is and in this case actually we
didn't have to wait for much longer like
already here now we reached a level of
significance where we might be confident
we might still decide to deploy it right
I mean it's just an information that we
provide it's not making the decision for
you but now you basically know what risk
you're taking on when we're making these
decisions okay I'll take more questions
at the end but I want to get to the
advanced example okay if you present a
PI data you have to have a ipython
notebook so yeah this is a fun little
model I built to like sort of counter
the deep learning track that's going on
in the other room so that you guys don't
miss out so I built a base in neural
network and I'm gonna go over that
fairly quickly and use like a lot of
lingo just assuming that those people
who know will understand it but what I
did is I just created these two
distributions using so I could learn you
can generate all kind of data sets and
the key thing is well it's two classes
binary classification and they are not
linearly separable right so a sigmoid
'el a sigma logistic regression which is
like fitted through here but it wouldn't
really solve the task in a satisfying
way a little bit so instead what I'm
doing is I'm building a Bayesian network
and I have my data X train and y train
so I use a train and a test set and I
want to of course train the model on the
train data and then later I want to make
predictions I have to switch out that
data of the model and this is now Theano
stuff where I have to create a shared
variable for my in and outputs
that I can later change the values in
here when I want to make other
predictions when he was five hidden
neurons here I'm just creating
initialization for the weights of my
neural network and this is what the
model looks like in PI MC 3 so we can
have that boilerplate and here I'm
defining priors so these are my latent
causes right for the weights from the
input to the first layer from the first
layer to the second layer from the
second layer to the output layer output
neuron is just a single one and I'm just
going to place normal priors on these
centered around zero with the standard
deviation of one and I'm using the shape
because now we're doing matrix algebra
so I can just define the whole thing and
test Val means this is what I'm going to
initialize it with okay now I have set
up the my parameters the priors on my
model now I just have to build that
neural network and all that is really is
just applying the dot product matrix
multiplication between my input and the
weights of the first one then you apply
the non-linearity and here I'm using a
10 H you could use a sigmoid but
actually 10 H works better I found in
this case that's the activation of the
first layer then I just multiply that
with the activations of the second layer
and I and then I compute the weights for
the output just like that so this is
just like the boilerplate logic of like
a very simple neural network okay and
then my data in this case is your
Bernoulli so that means it's binary with
just zeros and ones those are the labels
that I want to predict and I pass so
this is what I'm passing in here there's
the output data and then act out it's
just the activation of the probability
estimate of the labels of all of these
and then I'm using a metropolis sampler
which actually works fairly well in this
model even though it's quite complex
actually and as you can see is forty
point five seconds it's for ten thousand
samples that's it's pretty good but not
all that fast so as I mentioned already
these samples tend to be a little bit
slow and that is one of the biggest
problems I think
of when you want to really use that and
now I want to predict on the holdout set
so as I already mentioned I'm gonna
change the values from the Train to the
test now these will be changed in the
model and I call sample PPC which is a
posterior predictive check essentially
I'm generating new Sam new data from a
model given the parameters estimated and
the key thing is that my predictions
actually now will not be just the best
fitting values but actually will be
sampled taking the whole posterior into
account so we'll also get uncertainty in
my predictions that's something that you
can't get otherwise and here I'm
plotting the predictions on the holdout
set and you can see that it's matching
pretty well and moreover sorry so we had
ninety-five point four percent accuracy
whatever that means but what is more
interesting is we can now also map out
the whole space so really try and create
predictions for every point in in the
space and then plot that and this is
what that looks like so now we as we
know if the color here is the
probability that that point with that
coordinate will belong to class 1 or
class 2 and you can see ok like as you
would expect this is basically what the
hyperplane looks like that that goes
through here and then we have so so far
that is everything you could have done
with just plain neural networks right so
we haven't really made use of the fact
that we're using Bayesian statistics
other than that we get uncertainty in
these parameters but something that you
can't do otherwise is now as I mentioned
get uncertainty in your predictions
right and I can just plot the variance
of my of that space that is getting
predicted and it's looking as you might
assume right so we're very confident in
answers over here but as we get closer
to that boundary our uncertainty in
these predictions increases and that's
really powerful if you imagine in
practice if you want to make
real-world decisions right I mean if you
train a model to pick whether someone
has cancer or not right you better tell
them the uncertainty in that prediction
right and not just like yes or no so
that I think is really a very nice
property and shows you that it's not
that like this probabilistic program
machine learning but actually a lot of
the machine learning community is using
the Bayesian framework to express their
models and build them as I said it's
really slow well I mean these samplers
have gotten reluctor but still we want
to be really fast sampling is not going
to be the way to go and fortunately
there is a different style which is
called variational inference where you
can instead of sampling from that
distribution you fit a distribution to
your posterior by making some
assumptions like that your posterior is
going to be normal and one really cool
recent paper that came out are from the
stand team is called a DVI automatic
differential variational inference and
that just allows you also unlike
whatever model you dream up do
variational inference on that and it's
gonna be really fast and we just
recently included that in PI MC 3 so I'm
really excited about that and this shows
you how to run that so again now we're
switching here back to the train data
because we want to retrain the model and
I'm just calling variational a TBI
instead of instantiating the sampler I
tell okay
run 2,000 samples and then it's gonna be
very very fast and this is basically the
elbow the evidence lower bound doesn't
really matter but it's Bailey the
objective function so you can see how
over time you optimize to a stable
estimate and basically then at the end
of that optimization so it's not
sampling it's optimization now you get
like your posterior and that will be the
mean and standard deviation parameter
that you also got a return okay and I
can do even one better which is you can
use a DVI on using mini-batches as well
so the problem also with baton statistic
is that to evaluate just a single point
you need to compute the likelihood over
all your data
points so for deep learning for example
right you just like pass in training
data once and then optimize and then
beta you're done
Payton statistics you have to evaluate
the same data over and over again so
that's got to be extremely costly but
actually with a DVI you can also use
mini-batches which is the subsets of
your data and that way you can scale to
arbitrary sizes almost bye-bye yeah just
using subsets but still getting the
correct answers in the end and that was
provided recently by Tucker Yoshioka who
did the work of including that in piracy
thing so I'm giving a shout out here I
just have to like redo the model and
this is what that looks like it's we're
not like completely set on the API but I
think this is pretty well the key point
is that we're creating a generator that
will provide me subsets of the data so
I'm just using 100 data points at a time
and then I'm passing that to the advi
mini-batch function with like which
variables should be like replaced it's
not difficult to like set up but in any
case it works and it's gonna be even
faster right so like now we could use
millions of data points because we're
only gonna look at 100 at a time and
also within here you can imagine because
this is just a generator you don't even
have to hold this in memory right you
can just pool from a data base inside
that generator and just provide the most
recent data to your privacy 3 model and
you this is just a show that yeah we
also converge even faster actually to
the correct answer so that was the
advanced example and I just want to
close by with this overview slide of
comparing the different approaches so as
I showed you hopefully publicity
programming you can also do prediction
right we can use a neural network model
can predict returns the key thing really
though is I think it's a great tool and
that's mostly what I use it for is
actually gaining insight into the data
building models
being very quick to reiterate these
models change them see what the data
tells me just learn about your data it
can track uncertainty and a much more
principled way than frequency statistics
and the assumptions on your data are
laid out in your probabilistic
programming right so if I tell you like
this is the model I use you can
immediately critique it and say like oh
that is terrible prior or something or
like I would do that differently and
then you can change around it and play
it so that is for me a key point and the
model construction happens in code right
it's just Python code and we have these
very general inference algorithms and
hopefully with like this new style of
inference algorithm with a DBI
we can also solve the speed and
scalability issues that bitly have been
one of the downsides here but as
selected as mark next time hopefully I
will convert that to check there's just
a whole bunch of links that you can look
up later but with that I'd like to thank
you for your attention
any questions
yep I think you misread the model is
actually the same there was a different
reason why I had to just replace that
it's using normal priors in both cases
and you're right that like these
variational inference arguments used to
not be general at all because you needed
to read like derive the update equations
and those were specific to the model so
you're back to your frequencies problem
this advi
does not require you to do that it just
like works on whatever it doesn't have
to be conjugate it just it can't be
discrete but yeah it it can be any
continuous model that you want can't be
hierarchical and everything
- yes so I didn't mean to do that
yes oh sorry the most of the
documentation that you find is gonna be
4pi mc2 so what are the resources for pi
m c3 and i think probably the best place
to start is it's still a weak spot but
well there we go
but the website has a tab with like
examples and there's like some really
cool simple and more complex models that
all PIME c3 and it actually is not just
like times t3 but it's also just
learning to model and explaining like
the different models so I think that's a
good way to start another great place to
start is the this is can be piece book
that is still PI mc2 but we're working
on changing that to PI mc3 if you want
to help out with that please get in
touch but this book actually is is
really well written it's the puppy book
because it has all these puppies on the
cover so not only do you get cute
puppies but also great introduction and
someone has done the work of converting
all of that to prime c3 all the examples
so you can find the link on the prime
c3po and basically go through the book
but read every it's just like read the
prime c3 version off the other book and
that's probably the best way if you say
okay I want to get started I don't
really know the statistics and behind
that in a principled way that is what I
most recommend doing
no but now that you say it actually it's
it's a really good idea yeah any more
questions please yes
yep yep so these the question was the
variational inference whether that is a
mean field approximation where you
assume that there we ignore the
correlations in your parameters and one
of the nice properties
well basicity and MCMC sampling is that
you do get the correlations in your
parameters something that was crew up if
you do maximum likelihood estimation but
these variational inference algorithms
ignore the correlations and just try to
fit a uniform Gaussian to that high
dimensional posterior using a normal
distribution in the transform space and
there is actually a previous version of
that paper showed that you can also do
estimation of the correlations that just
becomes a more difficult optimization
problem but it's it exists but it's not
implemented and this one directly after
me John cedar is going to talk much more
about that hierarchical modeling which
is a great powerful tool as well so
definitely stick around for that for
more basing goodness